hello everyone and welcome to a game i
was uh
trying to show for a very long time but
never actually got around to do it and i
feel like now is the perfect time to uh
show this game it's magnus carlsen
versus judith polgar from the 2012
quad wrangler unum tournament in mexico
city it's a rapid event
uh but also a blindfold event because
first they play a rapid game
then they play a blindfold game and if
the result is a tie
then they play two blitz games so it's a
weird event but uh
you know the the games that resulted
from the tournament are very nice and
it's a four-player
uh tournament uh magnus cross and lazaro
brazon
uh you did pogba and manuel eleon hoyos
uh four
so four of them will be playing and both
uh udit and
magnus won their uh won their first
match so here they face each other in
the finals and
this is the uh the first game of their
matchup so we're gonna check out the
game and then i'm gonna show you well or
rather you can first read the article
which is in the description below first
thing you will see
i saw the article when i was still in
the hospital preparing for my
for my heart wall surgery and i read the
article and i thought okay when i get
back home when i get better i'm gonna do
a video regarding this
as it seems like a very interesting
point of view uh on the entire
situation of men and women in the world
of chess so
if you want to check out the article
it's a very short hourly article i
recommend you read it
it'll take you like three minutes uh the
first thing you see in the description
below if you want to check it out before
watching the video
but you can also do it afterwards uh so
we're gonna get back to that
now getting back to this game uh magnus
has the white pieces so this is the
first game this is the
uh rapid game and then after this game
they played the the blindfold game
magnus got the white pieces in the rapid
game and he opened with knight to f3 so
magnus starts off with the retti opening
and knight to f6 sorry about that
uh we have c4 by magnus uh and now comes
g6 we have knight to c3 and bishop to g7
uh and now e4 grabbing more space in the
center we have d6
and d4 so transposing into the king's
indian defense uh we have castles by
udit and now
h3 today most popular is bishop to e2
but h3
still incredibly popular today we have
e5
uh all standard kings indian stuff and
now while you could
trade here and offer over a queen trade
let's say bishop g5 now offer a queen
trade
uh which is definitely possible uh here
we have d5 by magnus declining the trade
and it's considered the best here
uh and here knight to a6 uh that like i
said this is a game from 2012
uh nowadays uh well not a4 but a5 is is
the most popular idea
uh but okay knight stay six the knight
is now coming to c5 also preventing
white from uh
expanding with b4 to take away the c5
square
from the black knight have bishop to e3
by magnus and
now queen the e8 somewhat uh rarer
move today most popular is knights to h5
making room for this
f5 pawn uh but in those days uh unit
decides for queen to e8 and here we
have g4 uh g for uh
well uh defending against some very very
tricky lines because uh you have to keep
an eye on the f5 square for example if
you just continue developing let's say
you prepared a castle
there are some ideas like knight
captures captures and f5 you sacrifice
upon
a piece to create a a very strong attack
here so
magnus not interested in this especially
as it's a rapid game
uh goes for g4 now takes away the f5
square
from black and here knight to c5 now the
knight
enters here and it's still uh well uh
it's still very early for whites to play
b4 as the e4 pawn is now hanging so you
have to deal with that first
we have knights to d2 magnus adds
another defender to the e4 pawn and now
a5 unit does not allow b4 and now the
knight is nicely cemented on c5
uh if magnus wants to get rid of it he's
going to have to play bishop captures
which is not
the the greatest idea as this bishop uh
will be very much needed
uh white placed all of his pawns in
front of the king on the
uh light squares and he has a dark
square bishop this uh
dragon guarding the king so white will
definitely need his dark square bishop
uh and all of his pawns are on light
square so you don't want to be stuck
with a light square bishop here so
bishop to e2 and then now as
everything is uh nicely placed unit
decides to strike in the center with c6
attacking d5
uh and here uh there is uh there is a
game where
uh this position has been reached in
modern chess where it's known that h4 is
the best move
uh and it's a really it's a really
tricky position but in those days
such things were not known for example
here if you go for bishop captures on g4
uh it's just uh perfectly fine for white
you you can accept it and you don't
really care about this knight to d3
check because after the king moves and
let's say knight captures on b2
you can go queen b3 and the knight is
trapped not much for
black to hope for here so uh such
things that were not known then magnus
goes for rook to g1
and like i said it's a rapid game it's
not a classical game uh and
it is as of move 12 the disposition has
never been reached again so let's see
how this uh
unique game continues we have kink to h8
urid makes room for the
for the knight on g8 so she can bust
open the position
with f5 with h4 by magnus now
and knight to g8 retreating with the
knight and queen c5 adding more uh
pressure
well more defense to the to the f5
square we have bishop to d7 continuing
development and the magnus castle's
queen side now
uh we have captures and the five ones
and knight characters
on d5 we have knights to e6 now unit can
shift our knight over to d4 or
f4 if needed and the magnus continues
with h5 he wants the bus to open the
position
so you did of course defense this and
the knight here allows that so g5 the
knight
and now nicely defends the g5 pawn and
now a nice prophylactic king b1
as you never know uh what might be
lurking behind the corner
and here bishop to a for by you putting
pressure on carlson's queen
uh we have b3 just defending and now
bishop back to c6 and here
magnus has a few moves to decide uh what
to play like a4 is an idea to completely
prevent any counter play from black on
the queen side h6 is a
is an idea you could sacrifice a pawn uh
to open up the h file use the h file for
the attack
uh however magnus goes for the very very
cool
knight to b6 he says okay i'm attacking
your rook what are you going to do
well of course eugene moves it and now
comes queen to c3 magnus is just going
after the pawn he says i'm going to grab
the pawn i'm going to play a4 and my
position is going to be excellent
uh and okay jude says you can have your
pawn i'm going to try and
you know mix it up as it's a rapid game
that i like attacking who knows what
what might happen
so here attacking carlson's bishop
bishop back to f1
and now h6 you did a great attacker
herself
understands the dangers of allowing
white to sacrifice this pawn with h6 so
now magnus just calmly grabs the pawn
queen captures an f on a5 and we have
f5 finally the move happens but now now
it's a pawn sacrifice and you're already
down upon so what's
happening here well point is if you go e
captures an f5 then uh you
can just go knight f6 and this is a very
close position your pawns are not going
anywhere you're not going to be able to
attack here
and it's probably black will be faster
in bastille busting open the position
and at some point even if this happens
this bishop comes alive
could be very dangerous for magnus so
instead after this f5 idea
uh we have g captures by magnus uh now
uh this is a this is a very strong pass
pawn and now the the g file is semi-open
so we could we could use that and also
uh you have to be
wary of this uh queen captures an h5
idea
uh so here queen captures an h5 is
played but magnus says that's perfectly
fine yes you're attacking
not that but my rook here rook to e1
and knight to f6 now putting pressure on
the e4 pawn so here we have
knight to d5 not allowing the the
pawn to be attacked twice uh and also is
just a beautiful monster knight on d5 so
if yuri wants to get rid of it uh she
has to give up
uh the either the bishop or the knight
but magnus will only improve his pawn
structure here
so here rook the a8 first attacking
carlson's queen
queen back to b4 now attacking the pawn
here
and rook f2d8 and here uh like i said it
it's a very
very complicated position especially for
a rapid game
uh you have to decide what to do here
there are plenty of ideas a4
always used for useful move for magnets
you could go for knight captures an f or
you could go for knight captures on f6
uh all very very prominent moves however
magnus decides to
improve his position a little bit more
before deciding on any
uh such rash decisions however this is
uh
one improvement to many as after this f3
move his position is completely lost
but it's not easy to spot why it's
completely lost however it's enough for
you
in a rapid game to spot to spot it so uh
feel free to pause the video here and uh
well
win this game for you while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh wonderful idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen to h4
and i it's it's a super weird looking
move and if you're wondering
uh yeah okay the rook is under attack
but after the rook moves what's
what happens now well that's kind of the
point and here
the strongest is knight captures just to
get getting rid of this or even
this knight captures uh however you
place bishop captures on d5 and this
allows magnus to go to go for the
in-between bishop captures on f4
which would slow down the attack however
magnus goes for the uh for the main idea
of the capture fest on d5 so c captures
on the e5
and now jude's idea comes alive knight
captures on d5 and this was the point it
was actually a double attack the
queen was attacking the rook on e1 but
also x-raying
uh carlsen's queen here on b4 so now if
the knight is captured
uh just queen captures uh queen and uh
of course magnus loses the queen
so the problem is uh now carlson's both
uh both his queen and his bishop are
under attack so he needs to
figure something out but it's impossible
to defend the bishop all of the squares
from where you can defend the bishop are
taken either by the knight or or by the
pawn so magnus does the only thing he
can he has to give up a piece bishop
captures on g5
at least now maybe uh he he can still
continue the game and the point is that
if pawn captures then queen captures on
b7
white's position is pretty great the
knight is still under attack if the
bishop moves you have to
worry about rook to h1 the king and
queen are still in the same file
however unit goes queen captures on g5
now attacking carlson's rook so now his
queen and his rook are hanging
and there is not much you can do here
the queen still has no access to the
dark squares to keep an eye on the rook
so you have to trade here
and this is exactly what magnus does we
have rook captures on g5
knight captures on b4 grabbing the queen
carlson's rook still under attack has to
go back
and now you did not even bothering with
rook characters on a2
uh bust open the position with d5 she
wants to get her
rook into the game as uh you know
activity above all
so magnus traits here we have e
characters on d5 knight f captures on d5
and now knight to e4 uh and excellent
square for the knight
maybe some f6 ideas will be possible in
the future so
knight the e3 attacking carlson's rook
and the bishop here and here
uh we have f6 by magnus hoping for
knight captures rook because then you
get this uh
bishop capture with check and you get
two pieces for the rook
however you did not interested just
bishop back to f8
and now rook to h2 uh magnus saves the
rook
so rook ate the c8 now offering to trade
off a pair of rooks and magnus blocks it
with bishop to c4
here we have knight captures on c4 it's
a very dangerous bishop
uh he uh the bishop could help with the
defense of the pawn on f7 and you you
might have to worry about uh a a lot of
different stuff here so unit
is up material she simply trades knight
captures in c4 we have b captures and
the king to g8 now
uh we have rook to b2 going after the
knight here and now a rook to c7
uh not going after the knight as the
bishop still guards the the bishop still
guards the knight
uh just remaneuvering now the knight
cannot move as the pawn with hang but
now
rook to c7 uh preparing to double up
rooks on the d-file uh we have c5 now
the
uh pawn is nicely protected by the
knight end by the
rook here and also now the bishop no
longer guards the knight so here knight
back to d3
attacking the two rooks and now while
you could save it with rook to g1 check
uh magnus finds the very interesting
rook to d2 now if you trade
of course rook captures rook is coming
so rook
c to d7 as planned and then now comes c6
again busting open the position uh
hoping to hoping to get some trades here
however just b characters on c6 rook
captures on c6 and now
king to f7 blocking the the past pawn
uh we have rook to b6 and now comes
knight to c5
uh offering to trade off everything the
rook is nicely nicely defended there's
the
offer of a nitrate so you have to trade
something here magnus trades on d7
captures with check rook captures and
the knight back to f2
but now h5 by unit and it's very very
hard to play this
uh you're down uh you're down a piece
this
uh you has this extra bishop here even
though magnus is up upon and
it could be a very strong past a pawn
but it's incredibly hard to play this so
rook the c6
attacking the knight and now just rook
to d2 unit says okay you capture my
knife i'm going to capture your knight
so knight to h3
defending and now knight to e6 also
defending at the knight
uh and here we have a for by magnus but
now uh
feel free to pause the video for the
final time and win the game for you
in the quickest and simplest possible
way while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on supporting how
to trap the knight
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's rook to h2
uh and here there is uh nothing more
nothing more to be done here
and i believe it was uh in this position
that
uh magnus calls and resigned the game uh
and yes that is true i just had to check
uh but yeah i was in this position that
magnus calls and resigned the game
uh because there is nothing to do the
knight is lost uh if you try something
like knight to g1
then not rook h1 because rook the c1 can
defend the knight but
actually uh bishop to c5 and now there's
nothing more to be done
uh the knight has nowhere to go all of
these squares are taken
and uh even if you try something like a5
yes it seems like you can push or pass
pawn but just captures a6 and
the a7 square is covered by the bishop
so there is absolutely no counterplay
here
uh so yeah after this uh not that but
after the rook h2 move magnus carlson
resigned the game and
game one of this uh finals uh
uh tournament uh in mexico city goes to
you did polgar
uh the entire event ended ended by
magnus carlsen winning it because magnus
retaliated in the second round
which is the blindfold game and then
they went into uh
tie breaks where two blitz games were
played in magnus won both uh
both blitz games uh but uh this is uh
it's uh win she got against magnus and
it's quite quite
the win and like i said this game was
played in 2012 which is uh long
after uh udit's prime uh but uh
still uh what a victory against magnus
carlton in 2012
uh magnus was a beast in 2013 as you all
know he won the candidates tournament
and he faced vishwanathan anand for the
title of world champion and of course he
became world champion
so in 200 2012 magnus was an absolute
beast so
this is what i mean and uh like i said i
i want you to check out the article and
then uh you could comment just on the
game but if you're interested in the
article and
this idea of are are are women still in
2020 uh worse than men in chess
uh well professor wei ma from the new
york university has something very
interested
interesting to say about this so do
check it out first thing you see in the
description below
read it it'll take like three minutes
and then come back and comment uh
whether you agree with him and uh
especially if you
if you understand statistics then you
could also
shed some light on his uh uh well
statistics uh
usage although as he's a professor at
nyu i imagine he
uh he does it quite well uh but here i
also wanted to show you uh
this is uh carlson's uh record against
youtube polgar
in their entire career so in classical
games magnus carlson defeated dude
polgar two to zero with one raw
so no wins for you in classical and
including
rapid and exhibition games magnus
carlsen defeated judith polgar 11-1 with
five draw so this is
the game we've shown is the only game
unit won against magnus
uh but don't uh you know don't uh
be mistaken or anything this is uh there
are
plenty of men with far worse score
against magnus carlsen
so this is not uh any any sort of a
point of metric uh system or anything
it's just uh
you know magnus is an anomaly he's like
he's like neo
there's uh it's pretty silly to compare
him he's probably
he's not probably he's the the greatest
chess player who ever
lived uh so uh it's it's always very
very hard to
compare to him and to his uh well rating
and uh
just playing skill in general uh but
yeah this is uh
what i wanted to show you what uh what a
wonderful game and here
is uh just so you get a bit of a sense
because today
you have i think uh ho yi fun is the
only player i think uh who is uh
well not only uh in the top 100 i think
hampi canero is also
in the top 100 regarding women or i
could be wrong but i think it's either
just hoifan or hampi canero also
uh but here is the uh top 100 players of
july 2005 uh like i said when you did
was in her prime
so you can see it's uh uh first rank uh
gary kasparov then vishwanathan
vladimir kramnik petersfielder and
number eight in the world
uh that's uh regarding men and the women
both so this is
the uh the the actual top 100 players
is judith polgar in front of some
incredibly strong names like uh etienne
backrow
uh levan arun boris gelfand alexander
grisham michael adams alexander
morozevich alexander shirov alexey
shirov and
the list goes on so this is only the top
15.
so this is by far uh the best ranking
ever achieved by any uh any woman player
and
it's uh i mean not number eight in the
world that's is
simply incredible however it was uh
and never never reached uh before or or
again
so udit is sort of a sort of an anomaly
uh uh herself and chess uh but yeah
uh that's just what i wanted to mention
and like i said i was in in the hospital
reading this article and i thought you
you guys might be interested in this
so do check it out uh first thing in the
description below
uh very very very short article and then
uh you can
comment on how do you like it where you
think it's uh
it's a a good article is there some
uh points that are maybe not valid in
the article do
you know share your comments uh so
that's the game i do hope you enjoyed it
i i thoroughly enjoyed it it was
quite quite the beating magnus took even
though he won the event afterwards but
this game is just beautiful with the
black pieces of beating uh
magnus carlsen uh in those days it was
pretty pretty incredible
uh but yeah once again i do hope you
enjoyed it i would like to thank jabri
fahed
adelaine shangoli uh adam kelly uh sks
tax and accounting services and marco
suveri for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do read the article